[Music]
so
[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock here in the uk you are very
welcome to spend your breakfast with us
here at sky news whether you're watching
us in la singapore wherever you are in
the world you are very welcome to spend
the morning with us a late night trade
deal for a taxpayer-fueled intervention
to restart production of co2 at a uk
factory
but only for three weeks so what then is
the latest twist in an energy crisis
that's been sparked by rising gas prices
the environment secretary george eustis
is on the program very shortly also
today we'll speak to labour's former
shadow chancellor john mcdonnell could
there be signs of a civil war within the
labour party and
is space one of the final frontiers for
women we'll talk to one of the few
female space entrepreneurs as her firm
tries to get into orbit that's really
cool isn't it also
and the quest to reach uncharted
territory will speak to the young female
explorer trying to go where mankind has
never gone before it's wednesday the
22nd of september pipeline lifeline the
government does a deal to use taxpayer
cash to restart production of co2 at a
factory producing the uk's supply but
only for three weeks
i'm in cheshire the second plant that
produces carbon dioxide amid warnings of
further food supply shortages in the
next few months
and the business secretary is in the
spotlight this morning as mps prepare to
question him over the energy supply
crisis
a cozy fireside chat but no sign of
progress on a u.s trade deal with uk
ministers now considering joining the
existing u.s mexico canada agreement
the war of words takes off the boss of
easyjet tells ryanair focus on your own
business dr michael o'leary says
airlines will have to merge we'll talk
to mr o'leary this morning
i'm here with a flotilla of fishing
boats setting sail on the thames as part
of protests against industrial fishing
[Music]
toxic clouds of gas thousands forced to
flee their homes as a volcano on la
palma continues to erupt
australia quake causes damage in
melbourne shaking buildings to their
very foundations
[Music]
morning everybody news of a late night
trade deal and a government intervention
to get the co2 pipes flowing again are
one of the factors that supplies the uk
it's important as co2 is used to help
keep food fresh and also to deliver it
there have been warnings of food supply
shortages the deal will be funded by
taxpayers and will restart production at
a plant on t side and last for just
three weeks the other co2 production
plant is in cheshire
it isn't part of the deal so why not
zadir chaudhary is there for us this
morning hello to steady good morning so
that plant's staying shot for now
good morning yes it is uh this one is
the second one that produces carbon
dioxide as you say is uh expected to
remain closed i had to drive around
today it looks very quiet there are a
few cars in the car park other than that
not much activity going on but it is
crucial that both of these plants start
activity as soon as possible because of
course as you know they provide as you
said sixty percent of uh the the uk's
carbon dioxide which is required for all
of those things that you just mentioned
the nhs uses it it's used to keep food
fresh it's using the humane slaughter of
animals for example um the deal there's
not much that we know about it other
than uh that it is the government
providing limited financial support
towards uh cf fertilizer to the plant
behind me in their running costs and
that is in order to keep that to get
over that supply short shortage of
carbon dioxide we know that it's going
to be in place for about three weeks
and according to the department for
business education industrial strategy
that is so that the carbon dioxide
market can adapt to the surge in global
gas prices um
it has been welcomed by many
organizations including the food and
drinks federation and also the british
retail consortium which in its statement
last night reminded us that this isn't
the only issue
on food supply shortages uh it says that
the government must also address the
shortage in lorry drivers um and just
while we've got you as far as the plant
is concerned on t side as you were
saying that one is going to reopen but
it's only going to be for three weeks as
you were also mentioning that what
happens after that do we do we actually
know
no we don't know what's going to happen
after that but it's going to have to do
for now because as i said that these
plants are responsible for 60
of that carbon dioxide that the uk
relies on for all of
those things food production food
to get the animals slaughtered in a
humane way but also the nhs relies on it
uh really it's so crucial that both of
these plants open not just one and then
when they do that they stay open
okay um and just before so many
questions for you this morning on behalf
of our viewers uh
just remind us why we need this co2 when
uh in order to transport its transport
food but also um at abattoirs and the
like
yes so it's used by abattoirs for the
humane slaughter for stunning animals
before they are slaughtered to be sent
over to
meat packing shops and places
packing factories and places like that
but it's also used in packaging to make
sure that you know
food can stay fresh on the long journeys
that it takes to get to supermarkets
it's used for a whole array of things as
i said the nhs also relies on it and we
know how much the nhs needs it all of
its supplies right now even more so
because of the pandemic so it's quite
quite crucial that both of these plants
reopen as soon as possible great thanks
very much indeed for the update thanks a
lot and we will be at the plant of
course on t-side later on this morning
meantime
um the government is saying that it's
going to fund this american company at
least in the short term the environment
secretary george eustis is with us hello
tell us about this deal
well the challenge that we've had is as
everybody comes out of the pandemic the
whole world a lot of disruption in
supply chains some issues with labor
issues with shipping issues with
logistics
and this latest uh problem is that due
to rising gas prices with a surge in
demand for gas in parts of the world
this uh these two plants
have had to close because they've uh
it's not been economic for them to
manufacture the fertilizer that uh in
turn means that there's this big
shortage of carbon dioxide which is
critical for use in
the poultry industry the pig industry
other food sectors beverage sectors as
well so we've intervened to to basically
support this company with some of their
fixed costs
on a short-term basis just for a few
weeks so that we can keep that carbon
dioxide supply going and give the market
time to adjust and for other supplies to
come on stream how much is it going to
cost well we're i'm not going into the
final details of that because i know
lawyers were still working on those
finances
it's going to be into you know many
millions possibly the tens of millions
but it's to underpin uh some of those uh
fixed costs so tens of millions even
just for three weeks
it's a big costly plant these are two uh
big expensive plants and it's to help
underpin some of those fixed costs but
it's going to be temporary we we do need
in the end of the day we need the market
to adjust the food industry know that
there's going to be a sharp rise in the
cost of carbon dioxide probably going
from something like 200 pounds a ton uh
eventually up to closer to a thousand
pounds a ton so big a big sharp rise
it's a small component but a critical
component of their production and and so
the plant that's opening at the moment
is the one on t side but the one on
cheshire that we were just uh reporting
from outside of that's going to open as
well um i understand that both of them
are going to to reopen to bring those
supplies back online the challenge we've
had is there is another factory in the
uk but that's currently closed for
maintenance there's also another factory
that we often get supplies from in
norway that's also closed for
maintenance so we have this perfect
storm of two plants closing because they
don't have a market for their fertilizer
um because prices have risen
and two other plants that are currently
closed for maintenance once those plants
reopen then we'll be back into a
properly functioning normal market could
we not have seen this coming
well it's difficult to do this coming
because um we didn't foresee that these
two plants would need to close we've had
a very sudden spike in gas prices um
there's a lot of said turbulence in
global supply chains
at the moment as the world sort of comes
out of the pandemic comes out of
lockdown starts to get back to business
as usual we're seeing surges in demand
for gas that's having knock-on impacts
that you can't always predict and it is
always the case though that carbon
dioxide there are a few uh big players
involved in it it's a chemical process
these are big chemical plants it's not
where you've got hundreds of players in
a an easily functioning market you do
rely on big capital investment um
typically run by a few big companies and
has it been a happy deal or have there
been stern words
um look it's it's been we've been
pragmatic on this and we know uh that
the the truth is if we did not act then
by this weekend or certainly by the
early part of next week
some of the poultry processing plants
would need to close and then we would
have animal welfare issues because you'd
have lots of chickens on farms that
couldn't be slaughtered on time and
would have to be probably euthanized on
farms we'd have a similar situation with
pigs so there would have been a real
animal welfare challenge here uh and a
big disruption to the food supply chain
so we felt we needed to act yeah it
it's almost as if you're knee-jerking to
these problems though rather than
actually getting ahead of them you knew
that two plants were going to be closed
for maintenance you knew how much we
needed this co2 and yet we found
problems with the supply chain before
you've acted i suppose is what some
people would say
well we've acted before that problem
presented itself have we not really have
you been well i think we have because
there are some empty shelves and we've
seen pig farmers and other people on the
news saying these pigs should have been
already at market and we can't move them
because we can't have them euthanized
well look we have a free market economy
and that's right as a general rule we
believe that the market should adjust to
these and that companies should come in
this in some ways is an exceptional set
of events where we've got two plants
that are closed for maintenance that's
coincided with
two other plants that have closed cause
they don't have a market for their goods
uh we couldn't foresee that we do know
that carbon dioxide is a critical
ingredient we had previous issues for
instance in 2018 but it is the reality
that because it's
a byproduct of a major chemical
manufacturing process there are a few
big players
that control and dominate this market um
and that won't change when you have
these sorts of processes that rely on
heavy capital investment okay just final
thought on that before we move on to
other things um you said that the deal's
still being ironed out with the lawyers
has um production started again it won't
have started yet uh it will take uh i
understand probably about 48 hours to
get these plants uh up and running
properly but obviously we'll be working
very closely with cf fertilizers the
company involved to ensure that happens
as soon as possible an american company
our prime minister of course over in
america at the moment he's not coming
back
with a trade deal despite the fact that
he was pretty confident that he would be
able to it does really look as though we
are at the back of the queue doesn't it
well look uh president biden's always
been clear that trade deals are not
really a priority for him at the moment
but look not with us certainly well
we've done 60 trade deals including
an agreement in principle with australia
an agreement with japan which is a very
important trading partner we still very
much hope to be able to put together an
agreement with the united states um when
well look we we're not putting time
scales on it it's always better to get
an agreement we have one before the next
election don't you um we don't need one
before the next election but obviously
we would like one uh are you confident
of getting one before well we we are
confident that we will get one at some
point but it's just not a priority for
the u.s administration it's for us
though isn't it it is for us and we
don't we have this special relationship
still well if you look at what we have
achieved over the years we have made
breakthroughs on things like whiskey
where we've dealt with the tariff issues
we've got access now for british beef
this is the first time in decades that's
something we've secured recently we are
in negotiation with them to get access
for british land so alongside uh you
know the bigger comprehensive free trade
agreement that we'd hope to do at some
point there are a lot of individual
agreements on individual products where
we're making some good progress you said
we would have hoped to do that sort of
uh in the past oh we're still pretty
confident that we will get that deal at
some stage the pm's but we can't say
what sort of time
we want to do a trade deal with the
united states we've always been clear on
that we've never put a time scale on it
sticking points um i don't but at all
it's just not been a priority for the
u.s administration i think president
biden has been clear was clear during
his election campaign that trade deals
you know weren't going to be a priority
for the early part of his administration
but he is doing a trade deal of course
is new with mexico and also um canada
and we're quite keen to piggyback off
the back of that how would that work
well look we don't rule anything out our
preference is that we have a bilateral
trade agreement with the united states
and obviously we're also joining the
cptpp partnership in pacific and uh oh
we're getting into acronyms early in the
morning yes well it's a it's a
essentially a trans-pacific partnership
uh that's a
an agreement with a group of like-minded
countries it's possible that the united
states will be uh getting on board with
that as well so look um we're making
progress on trade deals in many areas 60
trade deals in place including as i said
particularly this canada mexico america
deal do we want to get on the back of
that one as well we don't rule anything
out but obviously with any trade deal
it's the detail that counts um our
preference is to do a bilateral trade
agreement with the united states we
still hope that we can do that but
there's not a particular rush to do it
with any trade agreement it's better to
get the details of the agreement right
rather than be in a rush and president
biden's always been clear that a trade
agreement isn't an early priority for
him he said that during his election
campaign
um it would mean we'd have to have that
pesky chlorinated chicken there wouldn't
it if we did it it jumped off the back
of that deal um my director in my area
is going look
uh you wouldn't have to because the um
basically the the the import standards
would be set by the uk
so-called sps standards are set by us
there's a prohibition on sale of poultry
treated with chlorine and uh no plans to
change that at all what the president is
quite uh keen on is making sure that the
northern ireland uh trade agreement
continues as it is now i mean how
important is it that a u.s president
should be involving himself um in
internal trade issues in northern
ireland it's not got anything to do with
him
well look the united states obviously
was involved in putting together the
belfast agreement so to be fair uh to
him he feels that the united states has
an island agreement as well
and uh agreement he feels he's got a
role in that but you know but what um
what we we want to help them understand
is that what we are proposing in terms
of our
changes to the way the northern ireland
protocol works is all about upholding
the principles of that belfast agreement
where it's about protecting of the place
of
northern ireland within the uk
as well as making sure there's no border
on the island of ireland so um the
provisions that we're putting forward
the proposals we have are actually all
about safeguarding uh peace stability uh
in northern ireland and that belfast
agreement u.s president disagrees um why
is he wrong
well i think um he's probably at the
moment just um you know reading the
headlines reading what the eu's saying
reading what you know ireland might be
saying which is that they would like the
northern ireland protocol
to work in the way that the eu envisaged
um we think he's wrong because the truth
is that unless we have a sustainable
solution that enables trade to continue
between gb
and northern ireland then we are going
to have issues and that itself would
become a challenge to the belfast
agreement so those who believe
as we do in the uh the hard one peace
and stability in northern ireland have
to make the northern ireland protocol
work on a sustainable basis and that's
why we have to revisit some of these
provisions around the way it's
interpreted and could it be a bargaining
chip for a trade deal with the us
um no uh the reality is that it's for us
to work out how we make the northern
ireland protocol work so he should
butter actually it really has nothing to
do with him well it's not a bargaining
chip in a trade agreement but it's um
it's legitimate for him to have a view
on it obviously and express that view uh
and we'll obviously explain to the
united states that's um you know
effectively what's what it's tantamount
to saying that potatoes grown in one
part of the united states can't be sold
in another part of the united states i
think when you explain some of those
provisions in detail it is understood by
the u.s government that that clearly
doesn't make any sense and therefore
should be um you know should be
revisited i'm guessing he knows all of
that
um well look um it's a very complicated
um uh piece of agreement the northern
ireland protocol i'm not sure he does uh
fully appreciate all of that we're
obviously doing what we can to help the
the u.s government understand that but
principally that this is an agreement
between
the the northern ireland protocols and
agreement between the european union and
the uk the eu
said that they're open to engagement
discussion about how we can make it work
um
what we're going to do about these pesky
protesters on the m25
well you know it is dangerous the the
the protest activity they have sometimes
deeply frustrating for motorists very
first trying to get to work uh of course
very frustrating when people are trying
to get to work go about their uh
business there has been a robust police
action so far to date i know that early
on some questions were raised yeah but
what did you think about them said oh is
there anything that you need well to be
fair my understanding is that some of
those protesters had glued themselves to
the road the police do have a duty of
care in that sort of situation but there
was some robust activity to to remove
those protesters but uh the the problems
continued we are seeking uh to take
legal action today we're supporting
highways england uh in that what will
that look like well i understand they're
seeking an injunction that would give um
powers of the police to be able to act
uh um you know preemptively should that
be necessary okay and what about these
people that we and we've seen being
dragged off the road as we speak some of
those people go back day after day after
day how are we going to stop them doing
that well that's why we're seeking from
the court some um you know strengthened
powers to deal with this particular
incident we do have legal processes
around these the right to protest is
very important we protect that but
obviously when that protest is uh posing
a threat to the safety of others we've
also got a duty to act
and the police are acting and acting
robustly in this case and they could
find themselves with the liberty being
removed from them i mean some of these
people are reverends aren't they they're
people of the cloth yes well look it'll
depend on the um the terms um uh only
injunction that the court's granted but
what would you like it to see well i am
we're taking legal action i understand
to seek an injunction that would give
the police um stronger powers to be able
to intervene you know preemptively to
stop these protests happening so that
you're not getting a situation where you
have to wait for them to sit on the road
cause chaos and then have to remove them
after the event okay but what if they do
and what if they continue they ignore
that they continue to go and sit on the
road and cause all sorts of problems for
hours and hours and hours for people who
are trying to go about their business
what should happen to them well look
that it'll be at that point well um the
truth is that if uh if people are acting
uh you know against a court order then
there's a there's a contempt of court uh
element to that but look i'm not going
to get into those hypotheticals it would
be for the not really officers and legal
advisers in government to advise what
should happen at that point but
obviously uh people
have to abide should abide by court
orders if they fail to do so then
they're potentially acting how
frustrated would you be if you were
trying to get somewhere like come and
chat to us on a wednesday morning at 705
and the motorway was closed and people
were just sitting in front of your car
yeah deeply frustrated so i can
understand how frustrated people are the
government understands that i know that
my ministerial colleagues in both the
home office and in the transport
department have been really on the case
uh with this talking to the police
liaising with the police and i think
what we've seen in recent days is some
quite robust police action to deal with
this protest and you support that yes
great to talk to you thank you very much
for joining us this morning thank you
and if you'd like uh more on our
interview with mr eustis and you can
watch it on catch up uh of course um and
um if you prefer you can watch it uh on
twitter right now uh you can catch up
with some of the um shorter version of
that on my twitter account i should say
at k burley or you can go to youtube as
well we've got a channel there for you
too
no they may have had a cozy fireside
chat but there were no signs of progress
on a post-brexit trade deal between
britain and the united states just
talking about that weren't we as boris
johnson met joe biden talk today though
that uk ministers are considering
joining the u.s mexico canada agreement
here's beth rigby with more
four years since a british prime
minister came to washington boris
johnson here now and very happy about it
and with some reason to be enthusiastic
the us back in the uk's international
push to address climate change and
lifting the ban on brits visiting the
states
at last the prime minister in the room
where it happens with president biden by
his side i want to thank you very much
for
the warm welcome to today it's great to
be with you in the white house
and this is a very important trip for us
in the in the uk
and we've seen some some great progress
just in the last
period
but discord 2 in one key area the
signing of a free trade deal little
progress has been made
and an irish american president with a
clear warning to the man by his side
don't allow tensions over post-brexit
trade rules to destabilize the irish
peace process
president trump said that the uk was in
front of the queue when it came to a
trade deal you seem to have a different
approach is that because of your
heritage your concern about
the irish protocol is that what's
holding it back when it comes to doing
this deal with the uk
there are two separate issues
on the deal with the uk that's
continued to be discussed
but on the protocols i feel very
strongly about those
we spent enormous amount of time and
effort in the united states
it was a major bipartisan effort made
and
i
i would not at all like to see
nor i might add would many of my
republican colleagues like to see
a change in the irish accords
at the end result having a close quarter
again plenty to be positive about the
body language and easy conversation in
the oval office suggesting that these
two men genuinely get on leaders who
have inherited a special relationship
and have clear common goals in some
policy areas around climate change or
security but there are big differences
too on areas such as trade where big
gaps clearly remain
on the surface this a close relationship
but there is real space between these
two men
things are off to a good start but even
special relationships can be hard work
beth rigby sky news washington
still to come on the programme for you
this morning relatives of those who died
in the grenfell tower fire for calling
for an investigation into discrimination
they allege was suffered by those who
lived there we'll talk to one man who
lost six members of his family in the
disaster at half past seven
also live at gatwick airport talking to
travel journalist simon colder as the
rules on so-called redless countries
change from this morning
and according to eight we'll speak with
the spanish red cross in the canary
islands who are helping thousands of
people forced to flee their homes
following the volcano eruption on la
palma
in other news the australian city of
melbourne has been hit by an earthquake
overnight the tremor was caught on
camera during the australian
broadcasting company's morning breakfast
show with programmes continuing
eventually
as normal
[Music]
footage shared on social media showed
docklands the suburb of melbourne as
alarms were heard ringing in the
distance following the quake
shaking also caught outside the city as
skiers coming down victoria's mount
bulla felt the impact of the quake oh my
goodness me can you imagine being in a
cable car and feeling that
wow
there are no injuries reported though
but there was some damage to buildings
with bricks falling onto the streets and
power lines knocked down
in other news for you this morning here
on the breakfast programme
australian police have clashed with
protesters after a third day of protests
over covert 19 lockdowns hundreds
gathered around the remembrance memorial
near the city centre the protest
followed the decision to make vaccines
mandatory for construction workers
tributes have been paid to a leading
conservationist who was killed in a par
paramotor crash in scotland dan burton
died and his colleague sasha dench was
seriously injured when their two
aircraft crashed near
sutherland in the scottish highlands
staff at a primary school in south east
london say they have been left
devastated after the murder of one of
their teachers police believe 28 year
old sabine nessa was targeted in cater
park south east london on friday evening
her body was found
excuse me the next morning by a member
of the public officers had arrested a
man in his forties on suspicion of
murder but he has since been released
pending further investigation
around 65 container ships are stuck
outside two of america's largest ports
and the latest sign of disruption to the
global supply chain the ships were
queuing outside the ports of la and long
beach in california which handle nearly
half of all cargo containers in the
country
gcse media studies students are to learn
more about the life of the manchester
united footballer marcus rashford
following his rise to fame off the pitch
they'll learn about his use of social
media and his stance against racism in
sport
an inquest into the death of the serial
killer peter sutcliffe will take place
today 10 months after his death
sutcliffe known as the yorkshire ripper
died at the age of 74 from covid the
serial killer had been serving a live
term at franklin prison in durham for
the murders of 13 women between 1975 and
1980
across the uk the covid booster jab
program is getting underway this morning
but in the rest of the world there's
still concern about the rollout of the
first wave of vaccines
analysis by sky news has found no
low-income countries are on track to
meet the world health organization's
target of vaccinating 40 of the
population by the end of this year
two-thirds of countries have not met
that 40 threshold but more than four in
five high-income countries have already
surpassed it
but the uk government says there is a
case of booster jabs since despite more
than 98 vaccine coverage antibody levels
are falling in the over 65s
greenpeace campaigners are organizing a
flotilla down the river thames this
morning as they call on the government
to reduce pollution and protect fishing
stocks
not many in the thames either our
reporter aisha zaid is on the banks of
the thames in central london for us now
hello to you so tell us what the plan is
good morning kay so the fotilla are
planning to make their way down the
thames down to westminster we're
starting at the royal docks in east
london you can see some of the boats
behind me some of them have
banners stating no fish no future this
protest is all about uh all against
industrial fishing they're calling on
the government to take urgent action and
ban some aspects of industrial fishing
they say
that it is it is putting coastal areas
and the uk's oceans into crisis now
industrial fishing it has abilities to
capture hundreds of tons of fish of fish
every single day and some of the boats
can stay out on the waters for months
super trawlers are often used as well as
fly shooters and the problem is that
they disturb seabeds they
can cause problems with marine
ecosystems and in turn this also leads
to local fishermen
not having any fish to catch
now defra have banned some forms of
industrial fishing including pulse
trawling and they say they're committed
to working with the industry to make
improvements
okay for now thanks so much thank you
glad to see she's got her safety vest on
let's have a look at what's happening as
far as as far as our climate change
dashboard is concerned um
as i've said to you before it does look
a little bit complicated it's not really
the top one is which fuels we're using
in real time you remember yesterday it
was an awful lot of fossil fuels that is
being replaced a little bit now by the
renewables the figure in the middle 36
percent
uh the next one down
that's how much warmer the earth is now
than in 1880 when records first began
and then the figure below that that is
how long scientists believe it will take
to reach the plus one and a half degrees
celsius figure seen by many as a point
of no return for the planet and finally
the big scary number at the bottom
that's the total amount of co2 emissions
since the industrial revolution and that
is how much we're spewing out in real
time
um now let's uh update you on the
progress of one of europe's biggest
and greatest living explorers
here he is we're talking about wally
the walrus
hello mate after 22 days no confirmed
sightings he's been spotted this time
in iceland since march he's uh well
traveled he's four years old relaxing on
a speed boat he weighs 800 kilos if he
wants to sit in your speedboat you're
going to say no problem
he was spotted in wales in ireland in
france in spain and also off the isles
of silly
and if you are wondering where's wally
going next experts predict he should be
in the arctic
later on this year he doesn't take a
boat he does tend to um swim himself um
and he has been seen off iceland now he
can travel again good for him that's
wally
um that i think that boat was uh in one
of the dublin harbours wasn't it or just
um just off the harbour there
good for him
you are watching the breakfast show here
on sky news wednesday morning lots of
stories still to come including
potential fallout from what we've been
hearing from the minister this morning
um
and he has been uh telling us
about the u.s uk trade deal or not also
the very latest on survivors of the
grenfell tower fire they say there must
be an investigation into the
discrimination they allege was suffered
by people who live there we'll talk to
the man who lost most of his family next
[Music]
more than 10 million pounds of taxpayers
money is to be spent reopening two
carbon dioxide plants in england the
government says it's providing help
following a drastic rise in gas prices
and a fall in global production the
environment secretary george eustis said
the government would be providing
large-scale support for factories in
cheshire and on t-side
it's going to be into you know many
millions possibly the tens of millions
but it's to underpin uh some of those uh
fixed costs so tens of millions even
just for three weeks
it's a big uh costly plant these are two
uh big expensive plants and it's to help
underpin some of those fixed costs but
it's going to be temporary we do need in
the end of the day we need the market to
adjust the food industry know that
there's going to be a sharp rise in the
cost of carbon dioxide probably going
from something like 200 pounds a tonne
uh eventually up to closer to a thousand
pounds a tonne so big a big sharp rise
it's a small uh component but a critical
component of their production um and so
the plant that's opening at the moment
is the one on t side but the one on
cheshire that we were just uh reporting
from outside of that's going to open as
well
i understand that both of them are going
to to reopen to bring those supplies
back online
and that within the next 48 hours um our
political correspondent tomorrow cohen
uh is standing by for us um this morning
um i know you're going to be hotting hot
footing it back here in just a second
tomorrow but talk to me about this first
of all it's a lot of money for a very
short period of time
it is but the very real prospect of
shortages on the supermarket shelves
even nuclear power plants having to
close down was what the government was
acting on and so late last night the
business secretary whose department i'm
outside at the moment did a deal with cf
industries the american firm that runs
these two as we've been finding out
incredibly crucial fertilizer plants
that provide much of our carbon dioxide
that's so important for all these this
food and drink production and keeping
our energy supply going so they're
hoping that those tens of millions of
pounds will be worth it only one opening
at the moment but the government believe
i'm told that that is enough uh to keep
things going in the short term what
happens after three weeks is still
unclear though
and while i've got you i was surprised
at how outspoken the minister was about
um
the united states trying to get involved
with the northern ireland um deal and
and basically the minister was saying
well joe biden's wrong isn't what he's
talking about
it really jarred for me how boris
johnson has gone to the us to try and
really repair relations with joe biden
getting together on climate change and
while meanwhile george eustis the
environment minister said that
we're not going to be doing a trade deal
with the us imminently not just because
joe biden made clear that trade is not a
priority of his with anybody until the
midterms but also because he thinks the
president has got it wrong on northern
ireland that the deal that the uk is
trying to make with the eu about the
status of northern ireland he says joe
biden is misunderstanding it and seeing
the eu's point of view i thought that
was a incredibly uh surprisingly stark
um comment from george eustis just there
and is possibly not going to help grease
the wheels in the u.s no i think you
might get a tug from downing street
later on let's wait and see i will talk
about it in more detail later on for now
tomorrow thank you
uh meantime um survivors of the grenfell
tower fire are calling for the further
investigation into the discrimination
they say people who lived in the block
suffered before the blaze now bill chute
care who tragically lost six members of
his family
in the disaster is joining us now hello
to you thank you for joining us on the
program there is a public inquiry um
continuing at the moment um how do you
feel that's going
uh it's still going ahead it could be
done better with the fact of them
looking into discrimination which
they're trying to avoid
um and we're trying to fight them to
have them look at because it's a crucial
part of
the investigation otherwise the fire
probably would have never ever happened
um
when you say
they could be doing it better what what
specifically would you like to see
happen
okay i would like to see the inquiry
look at racial discrimination
and how the families were
because of most of the people that died
was of a
bam origin um
they were discriminated
in who
they were and
because they were discriminated
this is the reason why the fire
happened they was not looked at they was
not
addressed and or listened to
before the fire
i see what you mean so you're saying
that that uh your relatives and others
were saying look there are problems here
but in in your opinion and that of
others um because of of their
backgrounds they weren't taken seriously
that's very correct you know we're
asking the government
by you know um i've set up a petition
asking the government to look uh
you know by you know asking your viewers
to
support us you know we could have the
government look into and add into the
inquiry how they were discriminated
and they should have never been
discriminated this would have avoided uh
the fire from the beginning
uh i understand the bill um tell me what
happened to your family
um i lost six family members in the fire
and many other beautiful people
that was that should have never
have been lost should have never died in
the grifford tower fire
what floor were they on in the tower
they won the 22nd floor you know
um
that should have never ever happened you
know that they could have uh
had they listened to the families and
you know we want them to literally
you know understand and you know we to
we don't want another grenfell to ever
ever happen again this is why it's so
important asking the viewers
to literally support this so we can
prevent
other
fires from ever happening again from
cladding that is still on
a lot of other buildings
yeah and we know that uh michael gove
has been tasked with his new job to try
to sort out that issue for other people
who
could potentially um suffer a similar
fate as far as the tower is concerned
it's what four four and a half years now
nearly since it happened the fire um but
you still want the tower to remain up
for now don't you
we would like it to remain up until
something is agreed through the memorial
commission where you know everyone's
taking part of what they would like to
just uh
decide to put up you know
um
it's it's it's it is this is a reminder
of our loved ones uh you know we don't
want them to disappear just as quick as
that
and do you have thoughts at this stage a
bit about what you would like the
memorial to be
um i really would love to see it being a
legacy remembering the 72 beautiful
innocent people a museum incorporating
maybe everybody's ideas or something you
know it's very important to add
everyone's beautiful ideas and this is
very important
yeah it's really important that people
continue to remember what happened in
june of 2017 and a tragedy that you live
with every day and bill we totally
understand that thank you very much
indeed for taking the time to join us
this morning thank you
god bless you okay thank you very much
thank you thank you
um let's tell you about what's happening
with travellers should we from today uh
travellers to the uk can avoid
quarantine as the government reduces the
number of countries on the so-called red
list
joining us now is simon colder travel
editor at the independent hello to simon
good to talk to you thanks for joining
us um this morning so what's changed
from today
well instead of having 62 countries on
the red list we now have 54 because
overnight we saw sri lanka pakistan
bangladesh oman the maldives turkey
egypt and kenya all disappearing from
the red list they are now moved to
the amber list from which you don't need
to self-isolate assuming that you have
been fully vaccinated and that's
tremendous news for the people arriving
here at gatwick airport this afternoon
from istanbul and it's also going to
spur a great deal of interest in
traveling to turkey in particular for
the half term holiday next month
and possibly also
egypt for some winter sun however half
of those countries including egypt the
foreign office still warns against
travelling to because of high levels of
kovid 19. so it doesn't sort of feel
very joined up and the other important
news is that if you're watching this
from your quarantine hotel at heathrow
airport or wherever i'm afraid you're
staying there even if you've come back
from one of those countries until you
have finished your sentence so going in
the right direction but we still have 54
countries on that red list compared with
germany who have no countries on their
red list the uk looking a bit of an
outlier
and it's incredible headlines some
people think wow that's amazing but as
we know there's always devil in the
detail like there's new changes coming
along on the 4th of october but people
don't know if they need
need to have a pcr test when they come
back from holiday or whether it's a
lateral flow test where is the best
place to find information because i know
from experience that depends where you
look as to what people tell you
oh sure yeah it's an absolute mess it's
incredible to think okay that in october
alone coming into england alone there
will be three different policies now of
course you can find out the latest on
the government website but it is
changing very quickly so up to the 4th
of october if you're fully vaccinated
then you've got to take a test before
you fly into the uk and another one
after you arrive um once the fourth of
october arrives you won't need to take
that test uh before you fly you will
still need to take a a pcr test on the
day you come back or one of the two
following days until some unknown date
in late october when that pcr test
becomes a lateral flow test i can tell
you that the traveler is confused the
airlines and the holiday companies are
absolutely furious as are the travel
agents who are doing their absolute best
to explain these rules but um there's a
still a great deal of incoherence and
chaos which actually led the boss of
gatwick airport yesterday to tell mps
that his airport had been hardest hit of
any major european airport um this used
to be the busiest single runway airport
in the world while there's plenty of
flights actually going off this morning
mostly to spain to croatia to malta to
greece and it's still nothing like what
it should be on a sunny september
morning
yeah and witch magazine apparently some
of their investigators ringing airlines
and they're being given the wrong
information at least half of the time
to the extent where people couldn't get
on aeroplanes because they'd got the
wrong information and that was from the
airlines themselves how frustrating
would that be when you get to the
airport with all the kids and the
luggage and goodness knows what else um
tell me about nhs certificates they're
not recognized in the eu at the moment
so when people read or go to portugal
and it says oh you don't need anything
if you've got an eu certificate that
doesn't mean an nhs certificate does it
no it doesn't and it's so sad i've
talked to people at gatwick and other
airports and working here who say it's
particularly portugal where you've got
because we've left the eu you have to
have a test before you fly many people
will see when they look at the
regulations and it's always good i start
off by looking at the foreign office and
what it says about the country then i go
to the country's own website to make
doubly sure
and on the portuguese one it says if
you've got a you eu digital covid
certificate you do not need to provide a
test and lots of people will see that
they've got a qr code on their phone and
it's uh you know it looks pretty
official well it is but unfortunately
we're not in the eu it doesn't count and
you do have to have a test as well
and belt embraces what i do is um
wherever i'm traveling in europe i
always um
show my nhs covid pass letter which you
have to request to be posted to you but
lots of officials at airports lots of
people running cafes restaurants museums
are delighted to see that as proof that
you have been double jabbed it's still
very tough to be a traveler things are
getting easier but in a fairly
incoherent and um difficult to predict
way
yeah
it certainly is and thank you for
clarifying that situation for us
just before i let you go do we know
whether the nhs difficult will be
accepted anytime soon in europe are they
looking at it
uh well it all depends who you talk to
the um government says it's working at
pace to get this um uh
set up um and some places like france
you can actually get the nhs code to
work on their local tousanti calvide app
which is good but elsewhere it's a
matter of crossing your fingers hoping
for the best bring lots of piece of
paper and don't rely on your phone
battery because it will probably run
out very good point simon thank you very
much indeed for the explanation thanks a
lot so a lot of red list countries
coming off the red list as simon was
telling us from tomorrow if you want to
check the list of course you can see it
online at skynews.com
but it is still incredibly complicated
go to the government website start with
and then take it from there but make
sure that you've got everything you need
before you fly because they will turn
you back at the airport
let's have a look at the air quality
did you know that if we all work
together we can really make a difference
to the air pollution around our schools
yeah we should really do that
high pressure hangs on in the south
where after a misty foggy start we'll
see some bright sunny spells but it's
wet and it's windy over the far north of
scotland and that rain belt though
narrow is going to work its way
southwards through the course of the day
temperatures still reaching a high of
around 23 degrees celsius in the fast
south that's a 73 degrees fahrenheit in
terms of air pollution we're looking at
low levels across much of the country
but with those light winds and fog we
could see one or two pockets of moderate
pollution in the far south
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
look at these dramatic pictures they've
been emerging of the volcanic eruption
on the canary islands excuse me a bit of
a particularly throughout this morning
for you uh estimating more than 6 000
people have now been forced to leave
their homes my goodness me how dramatic
wow
this was a scene as a swimming pool on
la palma was overwhelmed by lava
residents have been ordered to leave
dozens of villages and towns after a new
crack emerged in the comprehensive
volcano fourth earthquakes hit the
island shortly after the new eruption
vent open those are pretty dramatic
pictures gonna be talking to the red
cross on the island soon and uh this is
the scene on la palma this morning
marine authorities have established an
exclusion zone of two nautical miles and
say they think lava will reach the
atlantic ocean
joining me now is daniel lasada from the
spanish red cross emergency response
unit hello to you thank you for joining
us this morning how bad is it there
hi good morning
how bad is the situation
ah hi
sorry
i couldn't hear you um
the situation right now is uh is in calm
because you know the the pollution
of the volcano is
stable
but you know we have uh problems uh
with information
because you know the the
scientist committee can
come
give us more information about how to
develop this eruption
yeah and what sort of support are you
having to offer people
on the island daniel because some people
have had to leave their homes haven't
they
yes the spanish course
has different capacities
deploying the atom
the main capacities that we have right
now is a solder
device
here in the in the main city in santa
cruz
right now we are
we have no
much people
it's 140 people
right now in the in the center center
but these people that can
can't have any any any refugee or any
sorry any any shelter
with other
family or with other people that can
give them
to cover these this need
the others the other capacitors that we
had that we have deployed
are our
national response teams
especially in the sikh of socialist
support
and we are supporting at the government
with the logistics
with our teams in logistic emergency and
what about
tourists what is happening to
tourists on the island daniel
the tourists of the island
mainly they are
they are in tenerife because
they have to be moved to the other
island and you know the
they go over and say to the
operational agencies that
they they can be in the iceland uh
if it's possible
uh
and the people is safe
they are they have
their their needs covered
um yeah
do we know how much longer
it's going to be a problem for
um if we talk about the volcano
uh
anyone um
sorry nobody can
can know it
but
if we talk about the
the crisis
uh we think that it goes to be more than
more than months
finally the people lose
their houses
their properties and the livelihoods are
cracking the area
because finally it's not only the the
houses here there are a lot of
banana brand
we're going to have to leave it there
i'm so sorry but thank you very much
indeed for joining us on the programme
this morning
gracias